So I've wanted to do this for years
and recently I was on Netflix
and I came across like a crime docu series on Lacey Peterson.
Lacey Peterson was like
8 months pregnant when her husband murdered her.
All of this took place in California.
The material point is that everybody knew about this case.
And it's always
really bothered me that we have an unsolved case here in Winnipeg
that nobody talks about, nobody knows about,
nobody cares about other than her family.
And over the last 21 years,
I have consistently shared the story of Sylvia Ann Gibosch
every time I'm asked to speak on m, m,
I, W,
G. To us.
On June 13th, 2,003,
Sylvia Anne Gibberish, 20 years old,
was eight months pregnant with her second child when she disappeared.
We know that she grew up in Swan River, Manitoba.
She moved to Brandon.
She gave birth to her daughter, Tina,
her first baby in Brandon.
We know that Sylvia went to visit her family in Swan River
around Christmas 2,002,
and that was the last time they ever saw her.
Sylvia came to Winnipeg
and there's conflicting information on whether she came
to Winnipeg to be with her partner
or to get away from, from him.
We know that she was staying on Furby Street
and her sister Nicole
has said that she got involved with some people that were
maybe not good for her. Sylvia's mother,
Merna reported her missing in October of 2,003.
And at the time I was working at Southern Chiefs Organization.
And I remember still to this day
very clearly reading the article on her disappearance
and the way that she was negatively constructed
like so many other indigenous women.
And I remember thinking like,
is like nobody caring? Like where's the urgency to this?
The headline dehumanized her.
We know that there's like
a huge difference in the way that indigenous women are portrayed
and constructed in the media
when they go missing or are murdered.
We're blamed for that violence compared to other people.
It has been 21 years since Sylvia's disappearance.
Sylvia deserves justice. Her mum and her sister deserve justice.
And they deserve to know what happened to their daughter and sister.
With another m m I W
G 2 US family member,
uh in Manitoba, Bernice Catchaway,
whose 18 year old daughter Jennifer Catchaway disappeared in 2,008.
And she always says and I quote,
she's been saying this for years,
someone knows something.
Someone knows what happened to Sylvia and Gibosch.
Someone knows the details of her disappearance.
Someone knows who more than likely harmed her.
And maybe all of these years later,
you are at a place now where you can share these details
or any information that you might have
big or small.
So I'm asking you to reach out to the Winnipeg Police Service
or if you'd rather not do that,
feel free to reach out to me directly.
I know that Our special advisor,
Cora Morgan would be more than willing to sit down and chat with folks.
Manitoba has some of the highest levels of numbers of m, m,
I, W,
G, 2 s.
Many of them are unsolved.
And for years,
I've said that we have individuals walking on our streets,
walking around in our communities
that pose a significant threat to indigenous women,
girls and 2 spirited
who are involved in the disappearance and or murder of Manitoba
Indigenous women,
girls and two spirited. Somebody knows something on these cases.
Seven years later, after the disappearance of Sylvia Ann Gibosch,
her cousin Amber Gibosch went missing in 2,010.
That's one family. We have so many families that have multiple
missing and murdered indigenous women and girls.
So I'm asking folks to find the courage to come forward.
Families deserve justice. They deserve closure.